Hey! Well, the middle of summer!
I know what you're thinking about.
Christmas!
I know, I can't wait either.
Here, come on!
I've got something really amazing to show you.
But you promise you won't show loads of people or stick it on the Internet.
Here, look!
Gift wrap elves, attention!
Sir, yes sir!
Santa's airborne gift wrap battalion.
The Green Ribbons.
Present arms!
Knife, mission scissors, tape guns, gift wrap, Santa pattern, sir!
Brilliant!
On my count, wrap that!
That, sir?
Let me hear your Christmas noise!
Ho ho ho, sir!
Ho ho ho! Go, go, go!
Quick, this way!
Hey, this is top secret!
Turn that off!
Arthur Christmas.
Wow, that's one big teddy bear.
Coming in November.
There's nothing coming in November.
Go back to your summer!
No polar bears in mission control!